we all know that Stargate Universe and
Firefly I am to
misbehave should never have been
cancelled it was a crime against sci-fi
fans and dare I say a crime against
humanity but are there other series that
were also cancelled too soon that hurt
me almost as much this is my top three
of the shows other than Firefly and
Stargate Universe that really stung when
they got cancelled welcome to citric
your SciFi TV and move a
[Music]
channel when I found out the Stargate
Universe was cancelled it actually did
cause an emotional reaction and I'm
British so for me that's quite a lot
that's like me falling on the floor
crying and hitting the floor it's it
really did Sting and it still stings it
was a show that was really starting to
get better as you know regular Sid
trackers I'm not the biggest SGU fan I
actually thought it was a little boring
at least at first but it was improving
it was getting better and it was a
storyline that I desperately wanted
concluding and at the end of the day it
was still Stargate so it was still
better than 99% of the other stuff out
there but what other shows stung me as
much when they were cancelled I've also
going to ask one big question
we point fingers at Netflix for being a
little bit cancel heavy but to be honest
four out of five of the shows I'm
talking about in this video were
cancelled by one
company get into the comments right now
and tell me if you can guess who that
company is have you done that okay the
first series I'm going to talk about is
a show called Almost Human brilliant
Carl Urban in it before he obviously
became is he an o in that series I'm not
really sure and fourl word happy but
don't you
worry Daddy's
home Carl Urban is just one of those
actors that I love him in everything he
does he's just brilliant so when I saw
that he was doing a new TV series even
though it was being produced by Bad
Robot but this was back before Bad Robot
ruined everything it touched I was
seriously excited he co-starred with
Michael eely and it was a little bit
along the L of another JJ Abram series
Fringe the basic premise of the series
is that science and technology in the
near future has just exploded and got
out of hand so all of the police were
being partnered with a like a battle
droid Almost Human
cyborg the series was incredibly
expensive and unfortunately just didn't
get the view and figures and it was a
massive shame because every episode is
an absolute Joy if you ever get the
opportunity to check it out please do
and
honestly it hurt me when I realized this
show had been cancelled I didn't see it
first time around because in Britain it
wasn't shown but when I did finally get
to see it and then it just
ended it hurt man it hurt and it really
is gutting that
fox decided to cancel it and if you put
fox in the commentaries a little bit
earlier when I asked you to well done
you because just like Firefly Fox
cancelled this show halfway through the
first season the
idiots Dark Angel was a brilliant TV
show by James Cameron it was basically
about a bunch of young genetically
engineered children that escaped and
then the story followed them in their
young adulthood as they were desperately
trying to survive and find out the
answers about their mysterious lives Etc
they were basically a bunch of criminals
as well basically criminals For Hire
they designed her to be the perfect
Soldier a Human Weapon then she escaped
now I love this show mainly because of
Jessica Alba because I love her and
anybody who doesn't is an idiot that's
it that's all I've got to say about Dark
Angel Jessica Alba no really it was
brilliantly well written it was
beautifully filmed it was obviously a
James Cameron production so it was done
well it was a really clever story it
really did mixed genres even though it
was a Sci-Fi show it did have a lot of
action it did have a lot of fighting Etc
but it also had a real tender side of it
and it had basically a bunch of very
young people desperately trying to
figure out who they were in the world it
touched many different aspects it wasn't
just fun and sexy and a Little Bit Sassy
it had an emotional heart as well it was
a show that was glorious in its day it
only made two seasons again it was
canceled mainly because
of fox and it was just horrendously
expensive to make and compared to how
many people were actually watching it it
just didn't add up so again thank you
fox for canceling a perfectly good show
finally the number one show that really
stung me when it got cancelled because
again this was another show that was
really starting to get its legs and was
really starting to get to a point of
Brilliance Terminator the Sarah Conor
Chronicles
come with me if you want to live
starring summerl who I also love very
much and Lena Hedy who went on to appear
in Game of Thrones obviously very
famously and she was in the um judge Jed
movie with Carl Urban actually she was
brilliant in that as well she played
Sarah Connor suml played a Terminator
there was a johon o Conor there there
was a guy from 90210 in it and he was
actually really good too Brian Austin
Green he was fantastic Garrett Dill hunt
was another Terminator if my memory
serves and he was amazing as well the
casting for this series was perfect
there was a lots of twists and turns
Sarah Connor never trusted Summer Glow's
version of The Terminator and the
relationship between summerglass
Terminator and John Connor was really
really interesting she would sometimes
be good sometimes be bad sometimes you
really didn't know either way you don't
know what you're about to do yes I do
you're going to kill me no John you
can't do this you're not doing the right
thing this is not the right thing John
things are good now things are fine now
I ran a test things are good now I'm
fixed now and that made the show really
really fascinating it rewrote some of a
cannon it had a few issues with
production Etc but generally speaking
this was a really clever show that was
adding a lot to the story it was as I
said it was brilliantly cast it was
beautifully written it was a brilliant
TV show I was glued to my screen week in
week out but again because of high costs
Etc Fox cancelled it damn you fox I'm
glad Disney bought you and I hope they
sell you these are three TV shows that I
was desperately sorry got canceled that
really were actually getting their legs
and really deserved a little bit more
trust from Fox instead of canceling it
why didn't they just try to you know
squeeze the budget a little bit
unfortunately that probably would have
killed them anyway but you know what I
mean give them another chance they
deserved it just like starget universe
and Firefly deserved more we desperately
deserved more of these shows like almost
human Dark Angel and the Sarah Conor
Chronicles as
well try saying Sarah con of Chronicles
quickly it's quite hard but guys am I
missing more series from this list are
there more TV shows that deserved more
that got cancelled too soon now I'm
thinking shows like Farscape but they
got four or five seasons so I don't
think they count but maybe something
that only got one maybe two seasons
those are the type of shows I'm thinking
about get into the comments and tell me
if you can think of any more if you are
new to the channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification it really
helps us out and you'll never miss any
of our new videos also you can go to
patreon.com where most of our new videos
appear first and you get to see them
without the adverts for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel and you get a free
gift after three months can't say fairer
than that also go to s.co do.uk where we
do articles based on most of our videos
and we try to add a little bit more
information for you to digest as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]